I'm sure you've all caught a perform at
the Emmy Awards last month it was
incredible but here's here's the funny
part of it is you got you were under
attack for like first of all the
greatest thing ever I was under attack
guys I was attacked well they variety
said that I lip synched which which by
the way it just means you're that bad
hey thank you for that but I sang I I
sang that and I was I was pretty bummed
no I know that's happened to me before
and I was like I wanted to call this
lady named Lisa I feel like any I feel
like any real singer would have been
like oh no he's saying that you could
you could tell yeah no but it was
actually a good thing like I was I would
got so mad about it when it happened to
me like years ago cuz I was like I just
worked my tail off onstage like and
somebody said that and then everybody
was like well maybe it just means you
did it so well it would they by the way
if I'm ever asked to do anything like
that again I'm more than happy to
lip-sync that would take away like all
the pressure
yeah it's like it's like a full day of
rehearsal like the day before and I'm
just like trying to learn like dance
moves and I'm not a real dancer or a
singer so I'm like not in my wits what
makes it yeah yeah you fell that's the
best yeah where where I feel like me out
there doing that it gives like anyone
hope it's just a guy out there who's
mute is like I will not stop talking
until you subscribe to my youtube
channel that's right and I could talk a
lot seriously not gonna stop yep still
here not going anywhere I see you don't
walk away from this